[Musique]
en raison du courage en la matière que
je vais vous vous soumettre c'est celle
du courage de défendre des idées et en
particulier de défendre des idées contre
le consensus aujourd'hui consensus on
leur a tout en longueur de journée vous
n'avez pas vous ne pouvez pas dire ça
parce que vous allez contre le consensus
et le mon propos ce soir c'est
simplement de dire que le consensus est
une notion qui est complètement
antinomique de la science la science
c'est le règne du débat de la
controverse est certainement pas du
consensus donc je vais prendre deux
exemples pour pour l'exposer et d'autre
part j'avais aussi dire que c'est
consubstantiel à cette notion de
consensus et de sons de pensée de groupe
ça va penser trouve n'y a plus de penser
puisque on pense comme les autres
membres du groupe et que
alors pour aller au noeud de la ferme
le travail des scientifiques c'est de
réfléchir de travailler sur un projet
déterminé et quand ils pensent avoir
trouvé quelque chose d'assez intéressant
aujourd'hui il rédige une publication
qui soumet une revue et son peuple le
manuscrit est envoyé des experts qui
veut dire c'est complètement idiot c'est
intéressant c'est bien et ça c'est des
politiques des pratiques maintenant
qu'ils sont qui remonte au 19ème siècle
qui sont bien établis et je dirais lâche
constation tout à fait général c'est
beaucoup plus facile de publier des
idées pas original que des idées
nouvelles ainsi jeté bin si je soumets
un article pour dire que les travaux de
monsieur dit deschamps bordeaux sont
absolument remarquable
didier assez d'amis pour dire avril par
on est ravi depuis ça si je dis au
contraire que ce qu'il a fait et on
n'écrit pas qu'il est idiot quand même
et on dit que baba laddé ville des
difficultés commencent et alors
l'histoire des sciences montre de ce
point de vue là qu'il ya des vraiment
des dizaines et des dizaines
de scientifiques quant au vu des prix
nobel
pour des publications qui ont été
initialement refusée par les remous
qu'elle y serait soumise parce que le
nouveau texte est choquant et la
difficulté c'est quand vous avez une
idée réellement nouvelle il est rare
qu'il ne subsiste pas des petites zones
d'ombré vous ne pouvez pas résoudre tous
les problèmes d'un coup et vous n'allez
pas attendre 15 ans d'avoir aplanir
toutes les difficultés pour le soumettre
pour des tas de raisons c'est la loi des
rendements décroissants avant tout moi
donc tout ça fait que c'est publié des
nouvelles n'est pas forcément n'est pas
forcément résident et d'autre part vous
avez aussi et ça l'histoire des sciences
irish de gens qui ont utilisé tout à
fait remarquable qui ont soumis pour
publication qui ont essuyé un refus et
qui ont manqué pour des tas de raisons
honorables le courage de
poursuivre et du coup ils ont laissé la
paternité de leur travail à d'autres
bons donc ce qui veut dire que des
choses ne sont pas ne sont pas toujours
très facile alors ça je dirais c'est ce
qui se passe depuis au moins deux
siècles à l'époque que quand les
journaux scientifiques modernes sont
apparus et la nouveauté qui est
profondément inquiétante c'est que
maintenant et j'en parle en connaissance
de cause c'est que vous pouvez avoir du
mal à publier un article et qu'après ça
les gens qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
vous bouffon censuré l'article font
pression sur la revue avec des moyens
qui sont plus d'ailleurs à des pratiques
palermitaine qu'aux pratiques vient
d'éprouver la science simplement pour ne
pas qu'on puisse dire que le compte que
ce fameux consensus est rompu il se
trouve que d'une partie des activités
relèvent du domaine des sciences de la
terre et l'essence de la terre sont de
ce n'est pas un hasard c'est un domaine
qui depuis toujours été animé par des
controverses la question du climat fait
partie des sciences de la terre pourquoi
pas parce que la terre a des tas
d'aspects qu'ils peuvent être compris
cas d'échec de la terre elle-même or
comme chacun sait la terre c'est immense
s'est hautement variable vous avez dit
vous avez des des mères vous avez des
terres vous avez des montagnes vous avez
des plaines et que avoir une vue
d'ensemble
de tout ça c'est extrêmement difficile
et
je cite ici à la propos d'un historien
des sciences bien connu que
beaucoup d'histoires de la géologie main
semble avoir été une affaire de grande
controverse parce que c'est inhérent à
les discuter du sujet dont vous
intéresser à ce qu'un ballon dans lequel
il se produit des réactions chimiques
vous n'avez pas de mal à comprendre que
c'est plus c'est plus facile car traiter
un système qui est à la tête de la terre
j'ai mentionné quelques calculs
contreverse extrêmement célèbre celui de
l'âge de la terre par exemple et il a
fallu deux mille ans
de réflexion pour ce qu'on puisse dire
en 1956 que la terre était vieille de 4
5 milliards d'années donc c'est une des
controversés plus longue il ya eu des
grands débats au xviiie siècle entre les
gens qui disaient que tous les
phénomènes géologiques et est régi par
l'eau et d'autres visées n'ont que
j'étais le feu on a eu d'après sa des
débats entre les gens qui disaient que
l'histoire de la terre était une
histoire de catastrophe et d'autres
qu'ils n ont que c'est le jeu continue
de force de la nature
on a eu après ça au cours du 20e siècle
la grande controverse la mobilité
continental des gens il disait et manque
des continents se déplace qu'à l'origine
il ya quelques centaines de millions
d'années on avec un mec un continent qui
s'est fragmentée et que du coup
aujourd'hui l'amérique est assainie
kilomètres de l'europe et c'est l'état
de cette chose-là donc ces controverses
ont existé tout bêtement parce que le
problème des points sont intrinsèquement
compliqué qu'on ne peut pas les résoudre
alors aujourd'hui seulement la question
à la mode que benoît a brièvement
mentionné c'est celle des réchauffements
climatiques et on nous dit que le
consensus veut que à fait réglé et que
toute personne qui n'est pas d'accord
avec cette idée et et
consomme au dos doit être muselés donc
le mon propos ici c'est de démontrer que
non le consensus n'est pas un argument
recevable en sciences c'est pas
pertinent pour ça je vais d'abord
regardé puisqu'on nous dit que le
consensus et l'activité scientifique
telle qu'elle se produit depuis 2001 je
vais dire non une raison très simple on
va d'abord regarder quelle est l'origine
du terme
et puis je vais prendre l'exemple donc
de la révolution copernicienne
pour bien montrer à quel point justement
le consensus de faire partie de
l'histoire et je vais faire quelques
remarques pour dire que le consensus en
fait est une revanche de l'état
d'arguments ya une forte affinité
religieuse alors c'est pas tout à fait
fortuit puisque aujourd'hui ces
réactions sur ce sont des réactions en
fait de censure de type religieux donc
on est certaine cohérence nda est alors
s'il y avait une seule chose qui devait
être tenu de mon exposé ce serait ce que
j'ai indiqué en bas de diapositives que
consensus ça aux tendres en sciences
autant de valeur que vu allait telle
entrée en matière de marketing vous
savez que c'est j'ai toujours été
surpris de voir que ça peut être un
argument de vente ouverts aux élèves
elle atterrit donc c'est un bon produit
alors en matière de consensus je prends
deux exemples un célèbre dictionnaire
tout ce qui a été fait au xviiie siècle
qui s'appelle dictionnaire de trévoux
là je prends l'édition de 1743 on voit
donc la page de garde tom tom second est
à la page on s'attend à voir consensus
qu'est-ce qu'on garde
bas on voit
qu'on sent qu'on s'entend
donc des dictionnaires fait cinq volumes
il est grand comme ça leveaux consensus
n'existe pas
curieux pour un terme qui est censé être
à la base d'activités scientifiques
depuis 2001 alors faisons invention dans
le temps alors gardons le nouveau la
boule nouveau larousse illustré en sept
volumes édition 1907 et là on va
consensus apparaît et consensus qu'est
ce que c'est dans ce hameau d'origine
latine et en terme d' un physiologiste
leur nation un accord dans les fonctions
des diverses parties du corps le
consensus vital
donc voyait comme 907 encore le mot
consensus n'a absolument aucune
pertinence en sciences
alors maintenant si imaginons qu
effectivement ce terme est toujours été
pertinent
que c'est ce que se serait-il passé
au xvième siècle quand monsieur qu
planica publier son cv naufrage
depuis l'antiquité grecque on avait
toutes les raisons de penser que la
terre était au centre du monde
on voit bien que c'est soleil qui tourne
le tour de la terre c'est la lune qui
tourne autour de la terre et si je lance
cet objet à 20 mètres dos je vois très
bien qu'il va retomber mes pieds si la
terre tournait il devrait il devrait
tomber trois mètres plus bas et puis
j'avais aussi qu'il ya des journées où
il n'y a pas un pet de vent
si la terre devait tourner sur elle-même
à l'it est importante on va avoir des
tempêtes à longueur de journée donc la
physique
impliquait que la terre est au sens du
monde il n'y avait pas d'autres pas
d'autre explication la zone m quand on
regarde l essieu qu'est ce qu'on voyait
bien envoyé d'abord que
ces dix mois c'est plus facile de
réaliser avec des à prendre des photos
pendant toute la nuit que regardent en
ciel mais déjà des grecs s'était bien
rendu compte que ce qu'on appelle les
étoiles fixes toutes les étoiles
on a au fond de profond du ciel soit
animé d'un mouvement circulaire autour
d'un point qui est
quasiment l'étoile polaire et c'est le
pôle nord donc on voit que ces étoiles
tournent et elle tourne en 24 heures
autour de autour de la kz2 l'accès pool
qui va du pôle nord au pôle sud donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui posait pas de
difficulté marquantes alors là où les
difficultés se poser c'est que
maintenant six ans représentent
système solaire ce qui est l univers à
l'époque on représente la terre au
milieu et à prayssac évidemment le
premier accord scellé ce qu'on a c'est
la lune puis le soleil vénus bien qu en
mars jupiter saturne et qu'est ce qu'on
voit ben on voit que la lune tourne
autour de la terre en grosso modo 28
jours 28 av joue au pardon
et que saturne mais 29 ans et que la
période de révolution croît à mesure
qu'on va de la lune et saturne
mais il ya quand même un problème
puisqu'on voit que plus on s'éloigne de
la terre et plus les pertes de
révolutions sont grandes pourquoi les
étoiles qui sont présentés ici sur le
schéma tourner en vingt quatre heures
seulement et non pas en une période plus
longue que maintenant avant
c'était une incohérence majeure du
raisonnement mais on ne s'est pas soucié
de cette incohérence parce que tu es tu
vois ce marché et ça a été pour parler
de tête à ma chronique le consensus du
4e 5e siècle avant jésus-christ jusqu'à
jusqu'au 16e siècle voilà il ya monsieur
copernic qui arrivent et qui en 15 143
publie son fameux traité d révolution
des orbes célestes dans lequel il
propose le schéma qui a présenté où on a
soleil au centre puis la terre la lune
et des autres planètes
donc c'est ce qu'on a appelé la
révolution copernicienne
la question qu'on peut se poser mais qui
était copernic
donc c'est un changement colossal de
repas station du monde alors je vais ici
je fais deux remarques
la première parce que dans le grand
public on dit toujours oui ça a été
copernic rencontré des difficultés parce
que il a prononcé le des chances de
l'humanité l'homme est au centre du
monde et il se retrouve expulsé à
tourner autour du soleil c'est
complètement fou c'est un débat des plus
grands à découvrir une des plus grandes
légendes de l'histoire des sciences ce
qui pose bien savoir c'est que dans
l'univers aristotélicien dans lesquelles
ont été jusqu alors
les régions les plus nobles étaient les
plus élevés de la terre et chez les
grecs là d'éviter promesses et d'éviter
première réside dans les étoiles dans
les étoiles fixes et que la terre était
en revanche la poubelle de l'univers
c'était la zone la plus méprisable et
monsieur montagne en particulier la
position de la terre
c'est la plus calamiteuse et fragile de
tous tes créatures qui se sent se voit
loger parmi la boue et le fion des
ordures du monde attachées et clouées à
la pire plus morte et croupit partie de
l'univers au dernier étage du logis et
la plus éloignée de la voûte céleste
avec la ziio dépit conditions égales il
est lui-même a bien dit quand tu es la
terre nous cherchons à l'inde lire et
elles rendent pas fait en tâchant de
l'assimiler au corps célestes et de les
mettre pour ainsi dire au ciel nouveau
philosophe on
combat ni donc c'est dire que la
révolution copernicienne c'était un
établissement considérable de pour
l'homme qui n'était plus dans le
pouvaient de l'hiver mais qui se
retrouvaient confondus avec des as tu
composes coller longtemps considéré
divin la question qu'on peut se poser
qui était copernic
la coop et annick c'était quelqu'un qui
avait des meilleures études qu'on peut
faire à l'époque
anniversaire à cracovie d'abord à
bologne à padoue a fait rare et qui
après ça été chanoine à frombork en
poméranie occidentale
dans un endroit le plus reculé
scientifiquement on pouvait être
alors y'a pas certains pas un hasard si
copernic a pu bouleverser la prestation
du monde parce que justement il n'avait
pas des collègues avec qui tous les
jours il racontait les mêmes histoires
comme l'indiqué l'archétype de
l'opposition la pensée de groupe si vous
l'êtes originale ne discutait pas avec
vous payer tous les matins prenez le
temps de réfléchir et c'est comme ça que
vous allez vous allez avoir des grandes
évolutions alors même chose les exemples
précités des dizaines je prends juste
celui d'einstein parce que ça des
personnes méconnues stein en me sentant
1905 propose l'hypothèse de la
relativité restreinte je vais pas entrer
détail ce serait un peu compliqué ce qui
hélas que einstein dissèque les vitesses
de liens et constante quel que soit le
référentiel c'est dire que si je me
déplace dans une fusée à dix mille
kilomètres heure et j'en vois la lumière
vers vous et bien la lumière va avancer
à la même vitesse que si je suis à
l'arrêt la conséquence de cela c'est
qu'on bouleverse complètement les
notions d'espacé de temps qu'ils ne sont
plus absolus et relatifs
donc deuxième changement de
représentation du monde le plus
important et qui bouleverse 2500 ans de
super consensus en quelque sorte là
encore qu'einstein c'est quelqu'un qui
était élève de l'école polytechnique de
zurich une des plus fameuses universités
occidentales et quelque 102 n'a pas de
trouver de boulot à la fin qui s'y
retrouvaient experts techniques
l'institut fédéral de la propriété du
ciel de berne inutile de dire que
c'était un enterrement de 3e place si
einstein a fait sa révolution c'est sans
doute parce que justement il n'avait pas
ses collègues qui l'incitait à faire de
la pensée de groupe et on a ici deux
très beaux exemples de rupture complète
avec ce qu'est ce qui est plus fort que
le consensus donc alors c'est pour ça
qu'il vaudrait mieux parler d'accord
unanime en l'occurrence
et cet accord unanime justement comme
j'ai tout à l'heure c'est une notion qui
a été très utile en termes en
réflexion religieuse
un exemple bien connu chez les chrétiens
il ya quatre évangiles qu'on appelle
canonique parce que ce sont eux qui sont
contre trois que les pas des guides
deuxième siècle un marc luc mathieu et
jean pourquoi pas thomas pourquoi pas
les autres parce que la vie des
communautés chrétiennes de l'époque se
sont spontanément entendu sur ces 4 sur
5 à 10 ans gilles alors on a eu
exactement la même chose en islam avec
les recueils de pop de faits et dires du
prophète ce qu'on appelle des idées a
dit et chez les sunnites ou chez des
chez les chiites au
aux 10e et 11e siècle on s'est
spontanément mis d'accord pour
reconnaître une valeur spéciale à
certains de ses recueils
donc c'est une religion la notion de
consensus à ce propos illustrent est
bien le fait que le consensus c'est quoi
ces décisions qu'on prend parce qu'on
n'est pas capable de ce genre de choses
évidemment je ne peux pas prouvé
mathématiquement quand les quatre
évangiles canoniques sont meilleurs que
les autres pareil pour pareil en est
simple et là où les choses justement de
vienne
devient d'importantes séquelles comme
lundi à célèbre un helléniste chenilles
ou bien connu c'est que nous vivons un
moment un peu étrange où la science est
dévoyée et où nombre de scientifiques ne
savent même plus ce qu'ils font ne
voient pas qu'ils ont basculé dans la
croyance avec ses corollaires les dom
les excommunications la censure les
discussions est devenu impossible la
raison est mise au service des patients
l'histoire des sciences qu'est-ce que
scène c'est une longue promenade à
travers un cimetière où les idées
longtemps accepté aujourd'hui repose
sans paix pour l'éternité la science est
inséparable du libre débat et de ce
point de vue là c'est un peu dommage
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de nos collègues
n'ai pas compris un propos que bracey
philosophe romain teulet au cinquième
siècle la philosophie grecque elle même
en effet n'aurait jamais été tenues de
six grands honneurs ce n'est pas été
nourri des conflits et des dissensions
des plus grandes ce avant donc le
consensus à sans subvention c'est
inacceptable
le libre débat est impérieux et tout
ministère de la vérité et va directement
à l'encontre de la science merci c'est
ce que je voulais le point que vous les
siennes
[Applaudissements]